ils ont quitté leurs balcons pour venir
au plus près du personnel hospitalier
devant l'hôpital de chalon-sur-saône cet
après midi une soixantaine de personnes
réunies pour soutenir l'hôpital public
ici chacun rédige quelques mots
plusieurs affichettes pour composer un
mur de messages adressés aux soignants
qui applaudit au foehn est donc
maintenant au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
important aussi de sortir aussi les
soutenir dans la rue vous allez très de
la santé c'était un bien universel
les querelles en prendre soin imaginé
par leurs homologues non content de gens
étaient bien là quoi est-ce que ce temps
là on n'est rien une attention bien
accueilli par les membres de l'hôpital
soutenu par quelques collègues de ce
vrai si la crise sanitaire semble avoir
marqué les esprits les soignants
attendent désormais de vrais changements
l'épidémie est passé mais leurs
revendications n'ont pas changé puisse
d'effectifs plus de moyens bien
évidemment ce serait on demande lui qu'
une augmentation de salaire ça c'est sûr
nous on en a marre moi ce que j'ai
remarqué c'est que ça peut pas durer
comme ça il faut un réel changement réel
accompagnement personnel d'entretien
caissiers éboueurs les métiers en
première ligne durant la crise était
également à l'honneur aujourd'hui
si j'enlève au smic souvent à temps
partiel souvent c'est des femmes
et ben on voudrait aussi que ces gens là
soient récompensés avec nos maçons du
spic de 20% et pour nous cette
augmentation les parfaitement faisable
la france est un pays riche
à l'issue de ce rassemblement tous se
sont donné rendez vous mardi prochain
pour une journée de manifestations en
soutien à l'hôpital et aux services
publics
[Applaudissements]